can I finish pleas record can I finish
please can I finish please you want to
interview someone or you want I want a
conversation no you're giving me the
lecture man I'm trying to inform you of
something you come here to be informed I
came here to for a conversation oh hey
that's me I bet you're wondering how I
got here well for that I'll have to take
you all the way back to when the Panic
first
started it's God it's God it's God
[Music]
do you guys remember our friend King
Wasim well after we've had a awesome
conversation with him he really wanted
us to talk to his shakes and his Muslim
Brothers at his local mjid at his mosque
and we were excited actually we were
like of course we would definitely talk
to them we' love to talk to whoever you
consider to be knowledgeable so he went
to the mosque on a Friday to meet up
with the shake of the mosque and this is
how it went watch this but if you want
to you want to know the the the the the
difference or the how Islam fears uh uh
abuse Jesus as a point talk to shake
he's the one to talk to not me okay for
sure he's the shake he's the
knowledgeable one so I I I bow to him no
no no bow to
Allah how you doing sir doing well I'm
doing how you doing yeah yeah yeah we're
just having the Interfaith dialog I'm a
Christian my brother's a Christian we um
and we wanted to get in into like get to
to the Muslim people and see into the
Muslim people yeah like instead of like
talking to Muslims online go to the
actual mosque and you know get
conversations you know and and get the
face to face get the feel you know we
missed the service but um you know we're
here now so yeah well we we do not
record ourselves here uh with video okay
we do audio but recording we do not
record
people uh in conversation
however if you like to conversate I'm
very welcome to sure sure okay is is it
okay then we don't do any recording so
as we could see here the shake does not
want to be on camera now this is what I
find interesting ladies and gentlemen we
have the other Muslims who are not the
shakes who are I would say lesser in
authority and lesser in um in status
they're more willing to come on camera
and discuss with us about the tenants of
Islam and the Quran and Muhammad and
Jesus and the prophets but for some
reason they are more willing to talk of
to talk to us on
camera than their shakes and imams are
now why do you think that is why
wouldn't the Imam or the shake be open
uh and excited to talk to us on camera a
couple of young Christian Brothers who
are coming on uh you know to to to ask
about Islam and to have a discussion
about your religion and you get to
spread the truth about Islam to the
masses not just to them but to also the
viewers who will watch this why wouldn't
you be excited and jump at the
opportunity i' I've always found this
interesting okay so so you said just
you'll be okay with if it's just audio
Yeah okay is it okay if the camera is
only on me and it doesn't have any of
the Muslims in the picture this is your
choice okay yeah this is your stra audio
okay yeah so just straight audio just on
me you guys can talk about okay for sure
that's perfect I wouldn't have any
problem conversating with you without
video okay and this is this also AIDS in
sincerity when corresponding with the
people sincerity for Allah any action
that we do as Muslims we do it for
solely for the purpose of Our Lord so if
everything you do as Muslims is to
glorify Allah and to progress the
religion of Islam
then why not jump at the opportunity to
spread Islam the truth of it and clear
up any misconceptions that the world
might have to viewers who want to know
why do why shy away from being unv video
and jumping at this opportunity being
excited to clear up some things about
Islam and to possibly get some people
interested in your religion why not if
it's all about the sincerity and the
actions toward Allah subhah wa taala
allaham not for YouTube you know thumbs
up well for more yeah well for for us
it's educational you know it's like cuz
it has a in instead of maybe the four
people here maybe we can do we can do an
audio recording or I can stand back here
and you can ask your questions but I
don't I don't stand even next to people
who do videos okay yeah cuz it could be
a mistake made we actually got our
answer ladies and gentlemen the reason
why the shake doesn't want to be on
camera is because there can be a mistake
made and he doesn't want to embarrass
himself so already what we can see here
is he's nervous he's nervous to have
this conversation he's nervous for this
conversation to be recorded because he
doesn't want to be caught making a
mistake
and then maybe even called out by other
Muslims it's a tough world to be in but
you're the
shake Subhan Allah get the shake right
but lahot he agreed to do the audio
discussion he agreed to be uh to have
the conversation with an audio recording
only so he's off camera so no worries
let's see how this goes so yeah go ahead
uh so about Jesus Jesus Jesus was the
prophet of God one of the best men that
walked on the face of the planet he was
born of miraculous birth he was sent to
mankind at the time to call to the
Oneness of the Lord to worship call the
people to the worship of Allah to the
Creator who created everything in
existence and this is the same message
at all of the people of the past who
were prophets and messengers of Allah
Allah is the name that Allah calls
himself as you all understand the word
God uh is one of the greatest men that
walked on the face of the planet him uh
also Noah also Abraham Moses and
Muhammad all five of them they are the
best of men the top ones right they are
the best of men and all of the prophets
we as Muslims we respect all of the
prophets all of those who were sent
Revelation as Allah mentions in the
Quran the messenger he
believe he believed in what was sent
down upon him from his Lord
and also the Believers believe in what
will sit down from the Lord from the
Quran we believe in the Quran we believe
in the which is the gospel we believe in
the Torah which was sent to Moses we
believe in all of the scripture that
sent to all of the prophets however
difference between the
Quran and the book which is followed by
the Christians is the book that's
followed by the Christians is a book
that has
uh been changed it's not the exact
wording of Jesus now I don't know about
you but this amazes me I mean this is a
shake he was just teaching and lo and
behold guys he has the same exact script
that every single Layman daa guy that we
run into has in their back pocket what
you have Jesus is a messenger of Allah
he was born born of a miraculous birth
Allah the one Creator the of the heavens
and the Earth they all taught the same
message all the prophets Adam Moses
Abraham Noah they all taught the same
message of one God even Jesus taught
them same message as one God but what
you have is not the words of Jesus
that's been changed the previous books I
mean there is there anything in here
that we have not heard when you come to
a shake I'm hoping with you know not
really hopes but I'm hoping that I can
get something different something
profound something insightful but I feel
like I'm just talking to a regular dude
on Tik Tok Jesus spoke the word he was a
he was born of miraculous birth and he
was a messenger who called the people to
the Oneness of Allah even him himself uh
he called people he said don't worship
me but worship the true
creator so can I can I ask us something
about this this the Quran is the book
yeah you wanted to compare the Quran to
Jesus the Quran to Jesus Jesus in the
Quran and Jesus in Christianity Jesus in
the Quran you said oh Jesus I thought
you said
andan Jesus in thean Jesus in yeah Jesus
in the Quran can yeah so you you made a
lot of important um notifications to me
cuz when I as a Christian when I read
the Quran I was telling Wasim this the
other day like I what what is important
to me is how the Quran talks about the
previous scriptures because it it
mentions the Christians it mentions the
Torah and Moses and all our prophets
right it mentions the gospel now it
would it now it doesn't make sense to me
when uh it's said that you know that yes
we believe in the Torah and the gospel
but we believe that they've been changed
because believe in the original
scripture when I the original scripture
yeah cuz Allah Allah uh this is one the
purposes of the Quran to clarify the
message that was in the Torah now as you
can see whenever someone is really
nervous they'll talk a lot they Yap a
lot but now this isn't just with this
gentleman here this is literally
embedded in the culture of Muslims
Muslims will talk and talk and talk and
not let you get a word in unless you
force yourself in there in the
conversation because they don't want to
hear what you have to say and they don't
want you to catch them slipping on their
words so their tactic is to talk talk
talk talk talk now I interestingly I am
in a position where I want to be
respectful to this to this gentleman and
he's my Elder as well so I don't want to
just be belligerent with him I want to
be respectful with him but at the same
time I also want a conversation to be
had so a lot of times when you're in out
there in evangelism you you have to find
a balance with um being able to inter to
to control the
conversation respectfully right without
setting the person off but this is one
of those cases where he's going to be
set off regardless if you talk if you
talk and if you tell him anything if you
catch him up on anything he's going to
be triggered and shut down the
conversation unfortunately that's just
what it is as you'll see see see that so
that's where I don't I don't I don't see
I read the Quran and clarify the message
that was in the in which is the gospel
Islam came to uh clarify that message
that had was lost through the scribes
and as you know there are scribes those
who are ascribe to Christianity that
they have written
books uh and ascribed these words to
Jesus so so how would you interpret the
verses in the Quran am am I right I'm
right right this according to chrisan
theolog the apostles that wrot they
wrote for even Christian Scholars of
today they have they have admitted that
the book that the Christians file the
Bible today that you all follow it's not
the actual words of Jesus no no they
don't they don't say that they believe
it's the words of Jesus just it's
written by the apostles like the
apostles record to us what Jesus said
you know s similar to how like the Quran
records what Jesus said you know it says
that Jesus said this Jesus said this
yeah the Quran is the Quran is the word
of Allah and we believe that the Bible
is the word of God that's that's that's
the connect that we have it's like it's
like you know yes men wrote men wrote
the Quran you did not write the Quran so
who wrote the Quran the Quran is
revelation from Allah this came by way
of Gabriel did you guys hear my question
who wrote the Quran and what does he say
he gives us the normal script the Quran
is a revelation from Allah given through
Gabriel is that what I asked let's see
if he eventually gets to answering the
question how did it get in book form all
right the Quran was Revelation and at
the time of the Prophet Muhammad peace
and blessings of Allah be upon them
Allah sent the Quran from that you
familiar with Gabriel yeah still waiting
on that answer you're familiar with his
mission his responsibility yeah what was
his mission according to your belief
what was his
and here we have a classic example of
the Muslim Shuffle instead of giving a
direct answer to the question asked the
Muslim because they don't know the
answer and don't want to deal with the
uh question will shift subjects and
shift topics to divert and pray to Allah
subhana wa tala that you will forget
what you asked so instead of answering
who wrote the Quran he goes what what
does your religion say about Gabriel
does does your belief talk about Gabriel
does it does it mention Gabriel at
all come on man shake what what what we
do what we doing here dog you supposed
to be different man you supposed to be
different out
here what what I've seen in the Quran is
that he brought down the
Revelation what does it speak about
Gabriel in your belief do you oh yeah
he's just a he's just a messenger you
know a messenger what what is a
messenger what is the just bring he just
brings the message what message whatever
God gives him this to come so this is
this is what we believe he's the
messenger he was a messenger and he
understand that he came the Revelation
is an example if I if I'm asking about
the written book Allah yeah I'm I'm
speaking to you about the uh the book
that we have the book we have is the
word it was originally a word spoken as
an example speak to you in logical terms
example I tell you a statement I'm a
messenger I come to you with a statement
and you are one who is rightly guided
good grief man who wrote the book dog he
see he says yes I'm speaking to that I'm
speaking to what you just asked me and
I'm going by continuing to say things
that have nothing to do with what you
just asked I'm going to answer
everything in the book except what you
asked and that is the Muslim tactic and
to maybe I don't know if he's hoping
this is what Muslims do they hope that
you get tired maybe that they they wear
you down with their yaal chapter 3:15
and and and so to the point where you
might forget what you asked and might
not even care about the answer anymore
or get lost in what a messenger is or
what a what an angel is and what a
revelation of God is and the jobs of a
prophet man I'm telling you the daa
script and the DNA is the same the
programming it's the same no matter if
you're talking to a Layman on Tik Tock
or if you're talking to a shake in the
mosque they're the same
bot let's proceed uh you're a messenger
to mankind I'm a messenger
you know you know as Jesus he was a
messenger an angel yeah Angel Gabriel he
was an angel who was sent with the
message of the Quran
what I I didn't know that you you didn't
say that two three times before this
moment now what I didn't know that
Gabriel was an angel who brought the
message of the Quran who knew who knew
not all in one time but in a period of
span years understand that so with so
with regards to this he came in a lot
gave him ability it's not it's not
Gabriel who came it's not words of
Gabriel the words of Allah and Allah
gave Gabriel the ability gave him the
ability
to instill the words that Allah gave ins
it and Allah made it easy for Muhammad
blessings I understand brother I'm in
the middle of saying something yeah I'm
just trying I'm trying to I'm in the
midddle I'm in I'm in the middle
respectfully please please just
respectfully I I want to let you know
I'm in the middle of saying I'm promise
I'm let I'm going let you finish I'm
going let you finish I'm just saying no
no please I know the basics of his life
I know that jel is a messenger sent by
Allah that recite gave gave Muhammad the
recitation I know that I'm just asking
how was the Quran written you said it
wasn't written by men right so the
prophet Muhammad he memorized he
memorized the
Quran I want you guys to put in the
comment section if you heard me ask if
Muhammad memorized the Quran go ahead
put it in the comment section did did I
ask if Muhammad memorized the Quran or
did I for the maybe third or fourth time
about this about this point reiterate
what my question was who wrote the Quran
you said men didn't write it when I said
men wrote the Quran you said no no no no
no it's a revelation so I asked you who
wrote it and we're still here and you
have not answered the question now
you're talking about Muhammad memorized
the Quran what is wrong with these
people real talk seriously bot mode
straight bot mode and he's a shake this
is what happens when we go to the people
of knowledge and taught the Quran to his
companions yeah his companions and it
was preserved was preserved in the
breast as Allah mentions he preserve it
in the breast by memory and even into
this day and time we memorize the Quran
as weak as we are and all of the sins
and mistakes that we have we have
ability to memorize the Quran and
implement it we Implement on a daily
basis we use we recite the Quran on a
daily
basis what what is what is what is bro
on what is he on what what what are you
on about
now right now I'm not really feeling
where you
come what is he talking about we we
we've sinned and we've we've met
memorize the Quran even though we sinned
and we have our mistakes as human beings
we still memorize the
Quran all because I asked who wrote
it that's all the we see why the man
didn't want to be on camera because as a
shake this is all he
has as a shake
this is what he's capable of he cannot
answer a question and he doesn't want to
have a pure dialogue with someone who
may ask real questions and challenge
what he says so he's in full panic mode
full Bop mode and if you try to
interject and join the conversation he's
going to accuse you of interrupting
being arrogant and not listening after
we're
listening and we let him speak and get
it all off even without answering the
question we had I'm sorry guys but I had
to go through this so so do you at the
time of the Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings of Allah be upon they were a
lot more stronger than us in memory a
lot more stronger than us in
understanding so when the prophet
Muhammad who was guided and strengthened
by his Lord the best of mankind to do so
uh
he relayed this message of the Quran to
his companions did they write it and him
relaying this message to the Quran yes
yeah thank you right so
so he finally gave us the
answer oh my goodness you can just guys
let's just celebrate God I just want to
thank my mom and and my dad for getting
us here to this moment wow we got an
answer ladies and gentlemen and you can
see the relief and and the pressure just
roll off my shoulders and off of my back
when he finally gave the answer I I
don't know if I've ever felt a moment of
Joy like this before wow what a what a
relief um finally got the answer the
companions wrote it so men did write the
Quran so why did you say no earlier Mr
Shake but WR it yeah it's different it's
different than just me writing it well
so now the difference between this is
one difference wait please letl this is
one difference between Islam brother
please cuz I want this to be a
conversation if I can I like this
conversation but I want to mention
something to you don't mind yeah I want
to look there's a difference between the
Quran being listen there's a difference
between the Quran revealed let me talk
to you Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessing and his companions later on
preserving it like was one of the
greatest preserving it in book form for
generations and generations to be able
to continue
memorize versus what the people in
Christianity have so now let me comment
on this please okay so just as you said
the companions wrote down the Quran the
companions of Muhammad wrote down the
Revelation that they memorize words that
I got you I got you I want I want you to
know brother I am very familiar with
Islamic beliefs and the foundation like
the basis of
Christianity can I finish pleas record
can I finish please can I finish please
you want to interview someone or you
want want conversation no you're giving
me the lecture man I'm trying to inform
you you've come here to be informed I
came here to for a conversation not to
be not to be lectured I I want to
complete my my St your lecture this is a
conversation I want to complete my
statement but you did though now it's my
to you can't tell me completed my my
thing my thing is my friend respectfully
I'm trying to have a conversation a
conversation is back and forth okay but
you you will not allow someone to
complete their statement I I listen for
a long time no you didn't you can leave
you can leave you you don't want a
conversation well we knew that you
didn't and there it is ladies and
gentlemen the moment that it's my turn
to speak he cuts me off and then when I
don't allow him to cut me off he then
says that you are not allowing me to
finish my
statement what you've had a long
statement you've been talking the entire
time you've been the only one talking
but now that I've caught you in your
words and I want to engage with what you
said you are now playing the victim as a
shake a grown man a shake playing the
victim saying oh you're not letting me
talk now or you're not listening what my
brother
just if you ever see this video and for
the Muslims that go to this Masjid you
guys recognize that voice you guys know
who this is notice the tactic of your
shake notice the tactic of all your
shakes this is the same it's it's no
different all of them are the same all
the Muslims are the same for the most
part they're all the same robot they
want to talk they want to overtalk you
when you speak they want to interrupt
when you don't let them speak they'll
call you rude but they'll interrupt you
because they don't want to get caught on
their
words and so now you can leave because I
won't let him interrupt me because I
won't let him uh be rude and because I'm
engaging with what he says directly he
wants to kick me out now and play victim
mode and Gaslight and say I'm not here
for uh for Education I'm not here to be
informed and yada yada Y come on
shake that that that that that don't
that don't work here man that don't work
here man that don't work here big dog
not you're not allowing me to complete
my statement you want to control the
narrative and that's Nar you're a
YouTube channel that's what you want you
want to control what you want to limit
you want to limit what someone tells you
no to question you should have more
patience I'm not here to be lectured my
friend I want a conversation you're not
here to allow someone complete a
statement no I'm I I listen to you
Patiently I listen to you patiently you
got to you got to be patient with me too
to allow me to come into have a
conversation read my statement and
before you but you let but you let me
talk and then you cut me off you see how
that works like you want me to listen to
you but you don't want to listen to me
this is what you're doing you going have
a good man you take you take care of
yourself yeah you take care of yourself
all right we try man we the audacity
this is what you're doing the hypocrisy
of the Muslims man the hypoc
to be fair it's not just Muslims it's
all Antichrist religions they all have
this cowardice the same cowardice DNA in
them they don't want to be on camera
they don't want to uh really talk about
their beliefs they don't want to be a
challenged they don't want to really
engage now I want to give exception to
the ones who do like if you guys seen I
had a very respectful conversation with
an Imam um a few months back he he
welcomed me into the mosque and we sat
down and we had a beautiful respectful
conversation back and forth he listened
to me I listened to him it was a
beautiful conversation matter of fact
you guys can check that out um right
here and the videoos in the link is in
the description I also had another
conversation with a shake with Ali dawa
Shake who was the same type as this one
who wants to talk ramble has no answers
and cannot engage with you directly
if you want to see that conversation the
link is in the description below as well
to that
video but this is what I learned ladies
and gentlemen I learned one that uh this
was before my speaker Corner experience
and this was actually it got me it got
me ready to talk with the shakes there
and to talk with the older Muslims in
person because knowing them they don't
want you to speak they want to interrupt
you they want to Waffle the whole time
and they're not going to answer you
directly
I already know that um so my fault in
this and this is where I went wrong is
not asserting myself earlier on um
trying to be respectful to the person
I'm talking to we've come to the mosque
right that we're on their property so
you don't want to be pushy but at the
same time we can't be pushed over and I
allowed him to get away with waffling
too much out of respect out of trying to
be respectful but there's a there's a
balance like I said and that's the
biggest thing I learned is that when I
notice a person like this you need to
assert yourself early and assert
yourself in the assert yourself in the
conversation early and don't allow them
to get away with the waffling and the
word salad don't allow them to get away
with the Appalachians chapter 2 verse 66
don't let don't let them get away with
that because and and I and and call them
out on it early on which is why you will
see that my conversation with Ali dawa
Shake was only about 5 to seven minutes
long didn't last 10 minutes because I
was very direct and assertive with him
and cut him off at his waffle but I did
it respectfully so I hope that you guys
enjoyed this please leave a like and a
comment below if you're not subscribed
go ahead and subscribe to the channel we
do this all the time live streaming
Monday Wednesday Friday 5:00 p.m.
Eastern Standard time I'll see you you
guys next
time oh my God logic
[Music]